bonjour jean pierre ouellet merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
jean castex et olivier verront rappelé
hier de ne pas oublier que le virus
circule et de vivre dans la vigilance
santé publique france note une nouvelle
tendance à l'augmentation de circulation
du coronavirus alarmisme ou prudence
exagérée prudence exagérée
personnellement je ne pense pas à une
deuxième vague cette année elle va se
produire c'est évident mais il n'y a pas
assez de facteurs négatifs pour que
qu'elle puisse exploser mais je vous
signale tout alors dit que le virus
circule et non ce sont les options qui
font circuler le virus quand il ya eu la
fin du coffre du puy dulko finances du
pardon du confinement et bientôt il ya
eu comme une une explosion des gens qui
ont eu presque d attitude suicidaire
on a essayé de retrouver de l'infection
de retrouver un petit peu la vie
habituel et cela a amené des
débordements mais ces débordements n'ont
quand même pas causé trop de dégâts
parce que c'était des jeunes gens en
partant en particulier qui n'avaient pas
de pathologie et dans ces cas-là si vous
attrapez donc ce coronavirus et bien
vous pouvez vous en sortir
malheureusement si un volant porte avec
vous si vous êtes porteur sain vous
pouvez tuer n'est plus les aînés les
seniors qui euros pas mal de pathologie
et ont une immunité qui est complètement
défaillante
donc selon vous a pas d' imminente
concernant cette deuxième vague on est
descendu si je ne dis pas de bêtises en
sous votre contrôle à 0.55 pendant le
confinement pour le patient est à zéro
on était à 2,8 avant le confirme on en
est où aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs ça n'a pas beaucoup changé un
le jeu comme je vous dis il ya
évidemment des clusters un des foyers
infectieux
c'est le nombre de foyers infectieux qui
bague qui pourrait déterminer une
deuxième vague mais je n'y crois pas
personnellement parce que tout cela il
ya une certaine dynamique le virus à une
certaine dynamique au niveau donc de
l'écosystème
et il va rentrer dans le rang mais il
faut savoir que ce virus il est à base
d'ail rennes c'est à dire le nuc les
otites ya ou l'adn ou la rn quand ça arn
il a une faculté de muter beaucoup plus
facilement ce qui fait que quand on va
sortir le fameux vaccin soit disant pour
l'automne je crois pas beaucoup au
mental soit disant qu'il va sortir un
automne
eh bien peut-être qu'il aura déjà muté
et il ne sera plus valable il deviendra
obsolète
si deuxième vague il ya même si vous ne
pensez pas pour pour cette année est ce
que le gouvernement pourrait ou devrait
améliorer certaines choses dans sa
gestion de crise on parle d' isoler
certains foyers de contamination
seulement et non le pays tout entier
pour que l'économie puisse continuer de
vivre
oui le coeur du problème est là le
colloque parce que si on se compte une à
nouveau et bien il va y avoir des drames
c'est à dire que évidemment l'économie
va s'écrouler cetera showmatch bon et il
y aura tous des sentiments négatifs qui
vont arriver là or la dépression etc qui
ne sont pas bons d'abord pour votre
propre santé ça c'est évident le stress
n'a jamais été bon pour le pour la santé
et alors les gens maintenance au parfum
on a vécu une période on a relevé tout
tout ce qui était négative tout ce qui
était un parfait mais maintenant je
pense qu'on est à même de gérer
il est évident que tous les grands
systèmes médicaux officiels ont été
défaillants rôle qu on le sait
maintenant donc on sait maintenant les
barrières les masques et cetera la
distance qu'il faut avoir on connaît
tout ça et je pense que on va en tirer
un profit et qu'il n'y aura pas le même
drame que lors de la première vague
justement s'il ya une deuxième vague à
ce que les hôpitaux sont presque le
matériel est là est-ce que
l'anticipation est présente
oui maintenant lieu pense parce que il
ya chedli et cetera il ya même les les
pompiers qui ont
qui ont râlé un petit peu parce qu'on
n'a pas fait appel à eux et à savoir
qu'il y avait des cliniques qui étaient
sur place et on s'est déplacés on a fait
tout un cinéma avec les avions
hélicoptères et serra qui n'avait pas
lieu
maintenant je pense qu'on a recensé le
nombre de lits et à moins que ce soit
une deuxième vague débordante mais on a
de quoi colmater tout ça merci jean
pierre willem d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes co
fondateur de médecins sans frontières et
auteur du livre tout savoir sur les
virus et y faire face coronavirus grippe
ebola strass et autres pathologies
virales aux éditions dauphin je remercie